un peu moins d'une heure de route au
nord démantèle la raffinerie shell de ce
carrefour 2 ressemble à toutes les
autres en alberta mais ici depuis 2015
la multinationale utilise la technologie
de captation et d'enfouissement du
carbone pour une partie de sa production
tous les ans à la raffinerie c'est un
million tonnes de co2 qui captive soit
le tiers de toutes les émissions
ces autos gatz frappe pour l'industrie
pétrolière c'est à ça que ressemble
l'avenir à l'aide de filtres le carbone
est retenue à la source puis concentré
sous forme liquide avant d'être
réutilisés ou enfouis dans le sol
une fois sous terre le carbone et 106
rester de façon permanente capable de
retenir jusqu'à 90% des émissions la
captation du carbone est devenu eu des
sujets de l'heure dans l'industrie
pétrolière
cette technologie l'industrie espère
pouvoir continuer à augmenter sa
production tout en réduisant l'énorme
empreintes carbone des sables bitumineux
le président de l'association canadienne
des producteurs pétroliers considère la
captation du carbone comme un outil
important même s'il admet qu'il ne
s'agit pas d'une solution miracle
l'engouement pour la captation du
carbone ne se limite pas aux pétrolières
le gouvernement canadien y voit aussi un
grand intérêt
dans son dernier budget le gouvernement
fédéral investit 319 millions de dollars
dans la recherche et le développement de
la technologie une somme importante mais
loin encore des 30 milliards que réclame
le gouvernement kenny ottawa au cours de
la prochaine décennie pour en accélérer
l'application
aussi prometteuse choix tels la
captation du carbone demeure pour
l'instant très coûteuse et les
gouvernements doivent massivement
subventionné son utilisation comme ici
un score fleuve
même si le prix de la tonne de co2 au
canada va passer de 50 $ en 2022 à 170
dollars en 2030 la captation du carbone
ne sera toujours pas rentable à court
terme
à n'importe où ce qui fait dire à
l'institut de l'énergie trottier dans un
récent rapport que la captation du co2
devrait être réservé à des secteurs
comme l'agriculture qui ont plus de mal
à réduire leurs émissions à la source on
peut pas se mettre à parler sur le
captage dans tous les secteurs où on a
des émissions un moment donné ça fait
une très très grande quantité
d'émissions à stocker chaque année par
la suite pour atteindre la
carboneutralité les gouvernements
devraient visite avantage sur d'autres
solutions croit le chercheur la majorité
des investissements devraient tu fais
pour être capables de réduire les
émissions
sauf que dans une province profondément
dépendant du pétrole la captation du
carbone est vu comme une planche de
salut f
si elle seule elle ne réglera pas tout
l'édifice environnementaux de l'alberta
la captation pourrait toutefois
permettre une transition énergétique
moins difficile pour la province